there are new signs of progress this
morning in ukraine's fight against
russia russian forces are still
devastating communities by air but
citizens are banning together to keep
them at bay on the ground holly williams
is about a hundred miles west of kyiv
talking with some of those people who
are fighting back holly good morning
good morning from the air russia
continues to reign death and destruction
on this country this school was hit by a
russian airstrike earlier this month
according to ukrainian officials though
nobody was killed but on the ground
ukrainian forces are on the
counter-offensive while russia is
struggling to supply its troops with
fuel and food according to a senior u.s
defense official
this video appears to show a column of
russian military vehicles being lured
into a trap in the town of vosnessensk
earlier this month helping with the
ambush was a shopkeeper alexander
fraser you little beauties he shouts
nearly a month after russia invaded its
neighbor its ground forces have made
surprisingly slow progress ukraine's
military says it recaptured the town of
makarev on monday a key strategic
gateway to the capital kiev and across
ukraine ordinary people have mobilized
to defend their homeland
at this checkpoint we met anatoly a pig
farmer okay loaded armed with his own
hunting rifle
he told us the biggest thing he ever
shot before was a goat but now he's
ready to fight the russians with an
improvised bomb shelter dug out by the
roadside this is your protection from
missiles and airstrikes
they've got tire spikes and other
obstacles to stop a russian advance
these are to throw in the way of the
tanks and yes disable them i'll show you
and vitali a green grocer showed us
their homemade arsenal of molotov
cocktails would you be willing to give
up some of ukraine's territory for peace
it's impossible to give our territory
away he told us i won't agree to
anything else
ukraine's fighting spirit is
breathtaking
the ingenuity and bravery of its people
extraordinary
but from the air russia is leaving
carnage in its path
this hospital was decimated by a russian
missile strike on monday say ukrainian
officials killing three
and russia has even deadlier weapons at
its disposal in an interview yesterday
the kremlin spokesman dmitry peskov
repeatedly refused to rule out using
nuclear weapons if russia faced a quote
existential threat
gail holly i am so in awe of the
ukrainian people the love and the
passion they have for their country is
like nothing i've ever seen before i'm
so glad you're telling these stories
thank you holly